hello there you are watching the press
preview the first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive in the next
half hour we'll see what's making the
headlines we're the red box reporter for
the times mari aurora and pr consultant
alex dean
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now the telegraph
leads on the treasury accusing business
secretary quezy quarten of making
misleading claims about plans to offer
an energy bailout to struggling
factories
that store is also on the front of the
metro with a picture of mr quarten and
chancellor rishi sunak and the headline
look who's not talking
the ft reports that metals tycoon as
sanjiv gupta is to inject 50 million
pounds of fresh funding into his uk
steel plants
nhs staff face abuse from patients over
long waiting lists that's on the front
of the guardian
the mail reports that there's a severe
shortage of gps with one family doctor
serving 2 000 patients in some parts of
the country
boris johnson on holiday marber is the
lead for the mirror
on the front of the sun tyson fury's
boxing victory over deontay wilder
and the star says sub-zero temperatures
are on the way calling it snowmageddon
oh chilly and uh we're joined tonight by
mario aurora and alex dean welcome to
you both let's start off first of all
with the the metro the headline there
look who's not talking and rishi sunak
and kwesi kwatem pictured smiling but i
don't think they're gonna be many smiles
today this is almost open warfare in the
cabinet isn't it alex
well i don't know about that but you've
been accused they've accused him of
lying
in no uncertain terms
i think that members of the public will
be looking at this
wanting these two departments to be
talking to one another there's no doubt
that we've got a crisis uh over um
energy and the need to supply both
businesses and homes and
in my view these departments should be
talking to one another and when if
quarter quarting jumped the gun and said
we're in talks
and the treasury said no we're not i
think most people will think
quasi-cartoons right we should be
seeing these departments talking to one
another over what we do next in business
and home supply so i i think uh quoting
is right that we should be talking about
these things and i think we should have
some continuity of supply and certainty
about it and it's a shame but alex i
wonder if you can comment though why
would the treasury
openly
disagree with what the business
secretary has said
what's the reasoning behind that
yeah it's a fair question and i think
that he's uh almost certainly said that
he wants to be in talks and perhaps he
thought that they begun some
conversation that in the treasury's view
hadn't begun yet but plainly it should
have done because we the public need to
have some certainty about what's
happening next in our energy
supply there's no um mystery about the
fact that there's
need to know what's happening next in
energy and for the last couple of months
we've been talking about where we're
getting our gas from and what's
happening next in energy and our
business secretary is only right to be
um
concerned about it and saying that's
going to talk to treasury about it so to
the extent to which they're not talking
about it yet i think most people will be
saying come on treasury talk to this
person and at the the extent to which
this is kind of airing their daughter
their dirty linen in public
to my um uh perspective this is a bit of
um the lack of opposition meaning the
conservative party can create some
opposition for itself uh
from some to my uh perspective kwateng
should be talking uh to sunak right now
and uh i would have thought they already
were so i can quite understand why uh
is where he is
uh murray what do you make of it that
the treasury have i mean however you
dressed it up they have accused the
business secretary of of lying and
actually gone as far as to say that it's
something he's done before
yeah i think it's extraordinary that
they didn't just say it's not true but
they also said he'd done this before so
it's kind of
it's probably a bit of an exaggeration
to say dragging his name through the mud
but at the same time it's not a good
look for the government to be seen to be
divided um not speaking to each other
not really on the same page and if quasi
quatting did say we're in books and
technically they hadn't yeah and they
would have been
i hope to be in talks because we need to
sort this out
just as you richla said um people will
be asking well why why are you not in
talks and why are you actively calling
him out and saying he's lying rather
than actually focusing on the problem
and fixing the problem people don't want
to see these kind of internal spats in
the party internal spots in the cabinet
they just want people to get on with it
so that they can go and fill up with
tanks they can go and buy their
courgettes from the supermarket and get
on with their lives but it's very
interesting that they decided to kind of
turn this into something that was a
strategic choice they didn't have to do
that they made an active decision to
call this out and say this is a lie he's
a liar and he does it often so it's not
great
see that's what i'm trying to get to the
bottom bottom of why why do that what
what do you think the strategy is alex
well if what you're trying to do is
ascribe blame somewhere and to me it
seems like the blame has got to sit with
the treasury press team because they've
decided to blame a
cabinet secretary that decided to blame
a minister of the crown who's seeking to
have conversations about the future of
our country rightly in my view and i
think mari is right most people don't
want to see this kind of internal
exchange now why they've decided to do
that that's a very fair question what
they've decided to do that's very clear
one department blaming another airing
their dirty linen in public and i think
it's a mistake i think these two
departments have got to get together and
decide what they're going to say in a
united position about what our future of
energy polities is going to be after all
people up and down the country are
looking now to the government for
certainty about where their energy is
going to come from as we run into
christmas and quasi quoting seeking to
have a conversation with the treasury
department about that quite right too
good on quoting murray let's move on to
the mail and this is a story that will
really depress a lot of people who are
trying desperately to to see their their
gp more than a thousand people
per
gp that's the average now that that
we've reached it's gone up i think by um
five percent this is really shocking
isn't it
it is and it's a kind of long-standing
issue that's been going on a long time
even before the pandemic i mean there's
been frustration of
eps and the lack of access to gps or the
lack of availability you know the system
where you have to phone up at nine
o'clock on the dot and if you phone up
at 901 you've missed all the slots yeah
it's all complete madness it's slightly
archaic and we shouldn't really have a
gp system where it's that difficult to
get
an appointment when it's something very
simple but also easy to fix but also
needed i mean i i moved on to a remote
kind of um video based gp system before
the pandemic about a year or two before
the pandemic because i was so frustrated
with trying to get an appointment and
most of the time i don't actually need a
face-to-face appointment but there are
people especially on depending on the
condition you have or how old you are
and your exposure to technology who
really do need face-to-face appointments
2 000 patients per gp is unacceptable
and something as well that's in the
piece which is really interesting is
they talk about a postcode lottery and
how um places with kind of higher
populations and more deprivation they
could be up to 3 000 people per gp and
then more affluent well-off areas have
got you know 1 600 per gp so there's
this kind of huge um massive gap between
people who do and don't have access to
gps that's only going to get worse and
it's what it's going to end up doing
it's going to end up actually
exacerbating health problems that could
have been nipped in the bird that will
then go on and treat it for longer in
areas where there's more deprivation the
first place which means you're likely to
have worse health outcomes in the first
place so it's not it's not great and
it's going to spiral on so something
really does need to be done about this
big question alex what do we do about it
well i think mari's put her finger on
with her discussion about the remote
appointments about how we may have got
to where we are now i think that the
coronavirus situation with lockdown and
remote appointments may have papered
over
the current situation because people
have been seeing their doctors remotely
for some time and that's led to a
situation in which people don't go to
the surgeries and you know what
difference does it make to the doctor if
they've got one thousand two thousand or
three thousand people by remote
appointments which you may or may not
get in the end we're almost certainly
going to need to recruit uh more gps and
we're almost certainly going to need to
have more ability to see
your gps which is quite a different
point to the number of gps
that we have but my own instinct too is
that we've got to have a hybrid
situation now where we could have moved
somewhat online because not everyone
needs to see their doctor
in person so we mustn't throw the baby
out with the bath water people who are
working people who want to dial in to
see their doctor in the middle of a
working day should still have the
ability to take a remote appointment to
still be able to call their doctor or
see them remotely see them online
rather than having to go and see the
doctor and take a half day or a whole
day off work um whilst they're doing it
my instinct in answers your question is
there's got to be a hybrid in answer to
this where the people who are really in
need the elderly people who
don't even have the internet people who
need to go and see their doctor in
person can do that whilst a working
person can call them up in the middle of
the day see them without too much
disruption to their timetable if we can
do that hybrid then i think we can
manage even with 2000
people nominally on the books
of a gp the number itself doesn't matter
too much it's the service you get as a
person that's the important thing
you could have a hundred people per gp
and have lousy service you could have 3
000 people that gp and have great
service as long as you get it right and
my instinct right now is we're not
getting it right the people who need to
see the gp in person aren't the people
who want to see the gp uh remotely
having to wait in a queue are having to
call back at a certain time in a way
that we wouldn't accept in any other
kind of business environment yes and in
the end that's what we've got to
remember you're a customer
no indeed i have to say that my surgery
they've adopted the the hybrid uh model
of which you speak let's have a look
quickly at the ft uh and this is a a
short piece um basically raising
questions over poland's long-term future
in the eu block tell us what's been
going on there murray
yes so poland's been kind of tipped to
be perhaps the next um nation to leave
the eu and this is basically a protest
that went on in warsaw
a kind of pro-eu proteins to say no we
want to say we like being in the eu and
it's kind of been found that about 80 of
people in poland are in favor of staying
in the eu so they're not too too worried
about it but there was the court ruling
recently um where basically the court
ruled that um eu law was kind of
slightly incompatible with the polish um
constitution and therefore the polish
constitution should always come first
and then victor obama came in from
hungary um and kind of supported that
ruling and said yes we should be able to
kind of implement our constitution over
eu law didn't best please the eu so
there's a kind of tensions there but i
do think at the same time if there is
overwhelming support for the eu and for
what it stands for and for staying in
the eu in poland then at the end of the
day for now we're not going to see a
kind of poland exit from the eu when the
majority of the population want to be in
it
yes uh 80 according to their
survey suggests that the polls want to
remain in the eu um let's have a look at
the guardian and we were previously
talking about um the the number of
patients that one gp is assigned to over
a thousand this story is about the the
long sort of nhs waiting list and the
fact that that patients are getting
irate with staff
nobody should abuse
anyone else i mean that's just a basic
matter of politeness but beyond that
people absolutely shouldn't abuse those
who are trying to help them when they've
got a healthcare problem and it seems
from the destroyer on the front of the
guardian that there is a new level or a
an accelerated amount of people abusing
people within the nhs whether that's
reception staff which is discussed in
this story or doctors themselves or
nurses who are trying to treat and help
them and whatever your concern whatever
you think about coronavirus whatever you
think about nhs or accident and
emergency provision there is simply no
excuse for abusing people who are trying
to help you within the nhs and we've
always
had a certain amount of unforgivable but
reported and and stable abuse within the
nhs on a friday night a saturday night
when people come in from
a punch-up or a troubled night in a
nightclub but this is going beyond that
it seems that we are now seeing an
accelerated amount of people abusing
those trying to help them within our
healthcare system
and i'm someone who's got profound
doubts about the way in which we provide
healthcare in this country whether we've
got it structurally right we boast about
it being the best healthcare system in
the world which you might wonder why
nobody's copied us but that doesn't
matter when it comes to your
face-to-face interaction with the
individuals on the front line who don't
deserve one iota of abuse and i i have
to say this kind of reporting reveals
abuse of people
and
hostility towards people trying to help
you it's got to stop mari how is it that
we've gone from you know clapping for
the nhs on our doorsteps on a thursday
night to this
yeah it's bizarre isn't it how we like
to kind of clap them and you know put
rainbows up in our window and then
they get abused left right and center
when they're actually on the job saving
people's lives or helping people it's
really just kind of discouraging and
disappointing i think having gone
through this pandemic as a nation and
having really kind of
understood the value of um key workers
and what they do
and then for this to kind of come out
this story to come out i mean i'm not
surprised but it is very disappointing
my concern is that do we
feel that because they're key workers
and because um we need them so much we
kind of take them for granted and then
we treat them like you know almost like
a shop worker i'm paying for this i've
paid my taxes so you better give me what
i want and you'd better do exactly how i
want it to be done and actually you know
it's a national health service it's
there to to help us all but at the same
time nobody ever needs that kind of
abuse so it's it's dispiriting but
unfortunate i don't think it's that
surprising
yes
you're probably right the sun will
finish off on uh tyson fury
has been victorious
alex what did you make of his
performance
i mean not the first time that this man
has defeated the world and he's a deeply
unfashionable uh character in our
national life if he were
doing this kind of performance in tennis
or football our entire country would be
celebrating because he's someone that
doesn't conform to the idea of what some
people think of uh the national hero
should look like we talk about it rather
less uh than we might do
if we were in those other pursuits this
is someone who is the best in the world
at his chosen pursuit i'm really proud
of tyson fury and i think that some
people um because they don't like what
he says and what his political views are
don't rally around this character when
he becomes the number one in the world
at his sport in the way that they would
do if he were in some other pursuit or
if he looked different or if he sounded
different in the end this is a great
example for me
of our perverse idea of diversity at the
moment where we want people to
look different but think the same very
interesting viewpoint
thank you we're gonna have to leave it
there